all right uh we're going to introduce
lift number
one um we do about four or five lifts
only U and our goal here is objective
strength gain okay so we'll review the
bench press lift number one so ronan's
going to help me out
here you guys can come around so you can
see
everything all right the first thing is
how to how to and where to position
yourself on the bench so when you start
out you're going to put your eyes right
underneath the bar that's what he's
doing right there okay so the question
here is how far forward or how far down
towards my feet am I on the bench I put
my eyes right underneath the bar that's
the answer
okay um you want your feet flat on the
ground and if you cannot do that then
you can make these risers I'm sure
someone sells them but we just made them
and again you just want a stable
platform you don't want the balls of
your feet being the only thing you're
touching the next question here is where
do I grip the bar okay you if you look
at the bar I'm not sure they'll show up
on camera but they have these nerling
marks one here one here and then the
inside nerling line and you use these
lines to gain a symmetrical grip between
your right and left hand your main thing
here is that your arm should not be too
open nor too closed and so the rule of
thumb is that your forearms are going to
be straight at the down position so
that's what he's demonstrating right now
okay if they're too uh close they'll be
in at a diagonal and if they're too far
away they're out at a diagonal so the
best way of doing this is have no weight
on the bar guesstimate where you think
your hands need to be go you would take
the bar off this is light for him so we
we're going to just leave the weight on
and then you come down and your partner
tells you a little bit more out a little
more in with your forearm you mark it
using those knurling lines so that you
have a symmetrical grip and then up goes
the bar back on and so when you now grab
the bar that's what you use so what he's
using his pinky on the inner knurling
okay so he puts both pinkies on that Inn
earling and now he knows that's where he
grips the bar
okay uh the path of the bar and we'll
also introduce the spotter at this
time so as you get heavy you don't ever
want to lift alone and we want to lift
heavy because you only gain strength by
increasing the resistance which means
you want to lift heavy so your partner
is standing at the Forefront of the
bench they have a good stance ready to
save your life if they need to uh which
could range from anything from you have
a cramp to you have a heart attack and
you're just completely out of it we
don't want that bar falling on you so
they need a very good stance okay and if
they need to what they'll do is they'll
drop one end on the floor and then they
lift only half the weight using the
leverage uh in that lean to just get the
other part off of you
okay um inside our gym and just like
wherever you're lifting if Tristan just
can't do it and he's crushing uh ronin's
unconscious trachea he would start
calling out for help and everyone would
join in and get that bar off of ronin
then you'd go Medical on Ronin okay but
so he the spotter here Tristan is going
to have a good stance and he's going to
do a over under grip on the bar which
means one hand is forward and one hand
is
backwards he works with the lifter
ronan's got the bar underneath his eyes
he's got his pinky on that Earl that
inner nerling so he has a symmetrical
grip with his forearm straight at the
bottom of the lift okay Ronin will count
one two three on three Tristan will help
him bring the bar to ronin's nipple line
one two three okay the nipple line is
the path to action for the lift so the
bar will go down it will touch your
chest not crush your chest and not
bounce off your chest but it will and
then it'll go back up and you'll do a
set of five so that was two 2 3 four
five on five your spotter assist you
with rcking the bar okay uh when you
lift you want to lift somewhere between
80 and 90% of your maximum because we're
only going to do five sets of five so
you're never going to do more than that
okay so uh just give you an example
Ronan what's your what do you want to
lift for your
80% uh let's do 8090 225 two plates okay
so can you guys help get that
on let's do both of them actually
so Tristan do what's that math right 245
okay so he's lifting
245 and if you're you're like what is
80% well
80% is like number five at set one you
make it but you know it's hard uh number
four and five at set five like you're
barely making it but you make it if you
need your spotter you're going to call
out spot and when you say spot they will
help you with two fingers okay so we're
going to demonstrate we're going to Fain
that Ronin is on set five a rep four and
you just can't get the bar up okay so
he's down this is set five rep four he
calls spot R Tristan will give him two
finger lift okay and then uh we'll
either take the bar off so Tristan will
give him a chance to do it with two
fingers only but if Ronin can't do it
then we don't fudge around with spotters
we just take the bar back off okay so
we'll do it one more time and Ronan will
this is all fake okay so he goes down
he'll say spot at the bottom Tristan
will assist with two fingers he'll do
the fifth set fifth rep he'll do the
fifth rep with two
fingers and then he'll take it
off we'll demonstrate a failure so here
he is on set five rep four again calls
for spot spot he's got two fingers he's
not getting it Tristan will grab the bar
and they'll together put it on okay all
right um a fully perform set looks like
this he's going to do a set of five of
this one two three
okay so as you can see around five even
on set what would this might be like set
two he's working to get it up there
that's your 80 to 90% okay um then what
you do as you're lifting and of course
you're eating and sleeping
correctly uh you add on the bench 5 lbs
every week every week okay and so you
take these 2 and 1/2 lb weights and you
just put one on one side and one on the
other you do that every week your body
will be able to make that adaptation and
you just keep doing that keep eating and
keep sleeping and as you as the four
disciplines prescribed and you'll be
able to do that and you are objectively
getting stronger with that addition of
those 5 lbs every week
okay that's lift one all right I left
off one deal one detail so if Rodan
keeps his back perfectly flat on the
bench uh what will happen is his
shoulder mechanism will impinge the
lowering of his elbow it kind of gets
locked in there so if you look his hand
level is actually would have the bar not
touching his chest so what you have to
do is take away that shoulder imp
pigment by kind of arching your back
like you see him doing and he'll bring
his shoulder the blades together and now
you can see that the bar is low enough
to touch his uh chest so just to
demonstrate we'll take a little more
weight
off take the
25 the incorrect way of doing this is
with a flat
back uh I don't want you to push through
the impingment but just to show how the
bar wouldn't be on your chest keeps a
flat back and that's where it goes and
usually people just let the weight take
it down but you're imp piging your
shoulder like that come back up please
so he'll uh go ahead yeah he's going to
fix his back by bringing his shoulder
blades together you get a kind of arch
there in the back uh you don't really
have to support your back with the bench
a lot of people think that they're like
oh I want to support my back so there's
no back involved in this bench in this
in this lift right now so you you don't
have to worry about the fact that not
all your back is flat on the bench you
you you will'll have a space right here
there's a space under there okay all
right so now he freed his shoulder
impingment by Rolling his shoulder
blades
back and he'll do the lift and now the
bar can touch his chest without that
tension or causing injury in the
shoulder area